The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So we're going to now
show some of the examples.
And so again, they're in our
directory here, Examples.
We're now in section 2, so we're
going to go to Applications.
And we have this section
called Perfect Power Law.
The actual example
codes are all these ones
called PPL 1, 2, 3, and 4.
We have actually a lot of
other functions in here,
which are actually
really useful functions.
They're the functions
that do all this stuff.
And maybe they should actually
get folded into the main D4M
distribution.
They're here right now.
They probably could be
cleaned up a little bit
as part of the homework.
But these are, again,
very useful functions
for allowing you to generate
and fit these types of things.
So I have already started
my MatLab session.
There we are.
So we will do the first one.
Going along here.
Figures.
So if we go and look
at what we did here--
so the first thing we did
is we set our parameters
for our Perfect Power Law fit.
So we set alpha at
1.3, a D max of 1,000,
and then approximately 30 bins.
We called our
function here, which
is in this directory, which is
Power Law Distribution, which
will create a power law
distribution from these three
parameters.
And then the first thing we did
is just plot a distribution.
So we go here, then
we go to Figure 1.
You can see there is
that distribution.
So our Perfect Power
Law distribution
with these parameters,
very nicely done.
Then moving along,
we can compute.
This is how you compute the
total number of vertices
from the distribution.
We just sum.
It could be the total
number of edges.
We can sum there.
And then we see that
the total vertices
was 18,187, 84,000 edges with
an edge to vertex ratio of 4.6.
We now have a function called
edges from distribution.
So if I pass in
the distribution--
essentially the degrees
and the counts--
it will then generate
a set of vertices
that is consistent
with that distribution.
And now I'm going to create
some permutations, basically,
of these vertices.
I'm going to create a--
randomly permute the edge
order with these two sets here.
So if I make a
random permutation
of the number of edges, that
allows me to permute the edges.
And I can also randomly permute
the vertex labels themselves,
and then I can look at
these different permutations
to see what kind of
grass they've created.
So if I don't permute the
data, I just have a0 here.
I just pass in the
vertices that were created.
I create a non-permuted
adjacency matrix.
I can then look at that.
And that just shows you--
this is the adjacency matrix.
This is in the plot.
It just shows you that I
just created a vertex that's
entirely self loops.
Not very interesting,
but nevertheless,
completely consistent
with the perfect power
of law degree distribution.
So likewise, if I just permute
the edges-- so basically,
I take my permutation
here, and I just
permute that-- this is just not
permuting the vertex labels,
but just permuting the edges.
To the next figure
here, 3, and we
get this distribution--
basically
start vertex, end vertex.
Looks fairly random.
However, you see the highest
degree vertices are up here
at 0, 0, because that's the
order in which the generator
spits them out.
It gives you the highest
degree vertices first.
And so although we've
reconnected them
with different edges, you see
that their vertex labels still
have an intrinsic order which is
corresponding to vertex degree.
I should say this
generates this naturally.
It's a very common way to--
if you have arbitrary vertices
and you want to put them
on an adjacency matrix,
one of the first things
to do is to reorder them
according to degree.
You'll always get some kind of
structure that emerges there,
and it's often an easier way
to see what's going on there.
And as you can see
from the previous data,
you saw if you ordered
things by degree
and you saw this type
of [INAUDIBLE] aha,
that looks a lot like a
power law distribution
just from the
scatter of the dots.
So moving on here.
So now we're just going to
permute the vertex labels.
So we are not permuting the
edges, just the vertex labels.
So if you see here-- and then
by permuting the vertex labels,
it looks random,
but fairly sparse.
That's because we still--
every single time,
we've moved the
vertex labels around.
But all the edges associated
with that vertex pair
still will ship
around [INAUDIBLE].
We haven't done anything
to break them up.
Whereas before, we
broke up the edges,
but we didn't change the labels.
And so then the final one, which
is the one that we typically
do when we want
to create random,
is we permute both the
vertices and the edges
to create a truly random
looking adjacency matrix.
And there you see
you have something.
And now what you
can also see here
is these high degree
vertices do stand out.
This is a very standard
power law distribution.
You'll see these dense
rows and columns in there
that are indicative of these
very high degree nodes.
When we just permuted the
edges but not the vertices,
these high degree
rows and columns
all got shifted up into
the corner of the plot.
So again, another way to begin
to look at the data in a way
to recognize structure.
And I think this
adjacency matrices,
once you start
looking at them, you
begin to get a comfort
zone, just as we
do with other types of data.
We begin to learn
what they look like.
This is a very good way
to look at the data,
because you can look
at a fair amount.
If I were to actually plot
the graph of 18,000 vertices
as a traditional graph of the
vertices and lines connecting
them, it would just be blue.
The entire screen would be blue.
There would be no way
to properly position
those vertices.
Here, this is
84,000 data points,
and I can still kind
of see it a little bit.
This is the limit.
100,000 edges is
the limit of what
you can put on any
plot to really see it,
unless there's some
hidden structure that
allows you to really,
really move it all together.
But the adjacency
matrix is a great way
to look at fairly large graphs.
So we generally do that.
So this is the procedure.
Create your perfect
parallel distribution,
create some edges,
create some permutations,
and then permute it, and
then you off you are.
You've just created a randomized
perfect power law graph.
Again, this is an example
of a code where you probably
might even just
take this program
and adjust it to
suit your needs.
And then, I think, we did that.
And then finally, we plotted the
degree distribution of a 3 just
to show you that I'm not lying.
And again, the triangle
is the original
and the blue was the thing.
And you see throughout
all those permutations,
our degree distribution
remained the same.
Even though they
look-- those would
be completely different graphs,
their degree distributions
are identical.
So let's move on here.
So this is just showing-- so
we actually rolled this up all
into one function here for you.
Ran power law matrix, if you
give it an alpha, a D max,
and an ND, it will do
those three steps for you
that I had in the previous
chart all in one thing
and produce an adjacency
matrix that's a perfect power
law based on these parameters.
And again, you saw we
have the same number
of vertices that we
saw and edges and ratio
that we saw before.
So that's all the same.
Now we're going to transform
this data, clean up
this data by making it
unweighted, undirected.
We're going to
eliminate self loops.
We're going take the
upper triangular part.
Here's another one
that's unweighted, no
self loops, different
versions of them.
And then we do-- you can
see what those look like.
So if we look at
the first one here,
this just shows the
unweighted, what
basically making the data
unweighted does to the data
set.
So the triangles are the
original data, and just making
it unweighted, how it
distorts that data set.
This shows you what happens
when you make it undirected.
So unweighted means
we took any cases
where we had vertices with
more than one connection
to them, if something
had five connections, now
it just gets one connection.
And so that was a
fairly big distortion.
A perfect example is if you
take a person's social network
graph, and if you were
to make it unweighted,
what you're saying is that
the connection you have
with your spouse is
identical with someone
that you emailed once or
that you friended once.
And I think we all
agree that that's
a fair amount of information
that's lost there.
And so again, encouraging
folks to be aware of that
and to be careful of
when they're doing it.
Again, making it undirected
just means we basically--
if I phone you a lot or I
cite you a lot in papers,
That's the same as you
citing me a lot, which you
lose some information there.
Again, this shows the
kind of distortion
that we get from
making it undirected.
And again, this
shows what happens
when you do no self loops.
Well, there's not a
lot of self loops,
so we only have affected
a few vertices here.
So in this case, eliminating
self loops is not a terribly
distorted-- doesn't really
distort the data very much
at all.
And then finally, this shows
the upper correlation matrix.
So when we correlated
the two, basically
multiplied the adjacency
matrix together,
again showing what
we saw before.
Moving on.
You can see the plots that got
eliminated from my PowerPoint.
MATLAB has defeated
PowerPoint's attempts
to deny you your education.
So again, what
we're doing here is
we're creating a
perfect power law.
This is a bigger one.
I wan a lot of vertices.
So this time, we had 50,000
vertices, 329,000 edges
with a ratio of 6 and 1/2.
We create our vertices.
We randomize the edge
order, et cetera.
Now we're going to randomly
pick a subsample of these.
And what is F samp set at?
It's 1/40.
So I'm going to take
1/40 of all the vertices.
Now I'm going to go and
compute that degree,
and I'm going to basically
subsample all of these.
And later, what you'll see-- so
let's just take a look at that.
So this just shows
that chart here.
So this is the original data.
Again, this is the vertex.
We're sorting the
vertices by degree here.
So this is the
highest degree vertex.
These are the lowest
degree vertex.
And each vertex is
getting a dot here.
So we have 50,000 vertices.
They all get a dot here, and
we've only taken 1/40 of them.
And this just shows you here--
If you only take 1/40 of them
and then compute their
sample, this is what you get.
Now, standard sampling
theory would say aha, well,
I know how to correct for this.
The way I correct
for this is I just
multiply my sample data by 40.
And we took 140, so that
means whenever I measure it,
the true value should
be 40 times higher.
So we can look at
that in figure 2.
So this is the true sample.
So again, we see for our
high-degree vertices here--
this is the highest
degree vertex here again.
So this is the
high-degree vertices.
These are the
low-degree vertices.
I don't know if I said that,
opposite when I mentioned it
before.
This is the highest
degree vertex.
And you see that by
sampling the data,
we're doing a very good job
on the high-degree vertices.
We're sampling them just fine.
And that's why statistics works.
If something is really
not rare and you sample,
you're going to get
a good estimate.
However, for these low-degree
vertices over here,
what you see-- by
multiplying by 40,
we're significantly
over-estimating
their probability.
As I say, this is
the curve that proves
that optimists and
pessimists are both correct.
There are so many rare things.
If the world is a
power law distribution,
it means that there are so many
rare events in the world, some
of them are going
to happen to you.
So it means if you're an
optimist, go play the lottery.
If you're a pessimist, it means
that lightning could hit you,
and you better just stay inside.
So there's just so
many rare things
that some really rare
things are going to happen
to you in your lifetime.
Most likely, those rare
things are very mundane.
But we can correct for this.
And so we have basically a way
here of deriving calculations.
So we compute the parameters
of our distribution,
and through these two functions,
compute degree correction,
and apply degree correction.
We can actually go back
and say all right, given
that we believe the data is
power law and we've sampled it,
can we then come up with a
more uniform correction that
basically gives us a better
estimate that works at both
the high and the low end?
And that's what you see here.
So basically, we
haven't changed.
The correction
hasn't changed here.
But we've downgraded
these lower ones.
And essentially,
what we're doing
is instead of just using the
average as the statistic,
we're using the median.
So we're using, essentially,
a quantile-based correction
here, a 50th percent
quantile-based based correction
here.
And that causes us to lower the
estimates of these vertices.
And so it would be
a better estimate
and allow you to do
the sampling of that.
Very good.
And our final demo.
So now what we're doing
is power law fitting.
And so we have the
routines for doing that.
So again, here's
our distribution.
It's a power law of 1.3.
We've set D max to be 2,000
and about 60-ish bins.
We create our
parallel distribution.
It has 50,000 vertices,
329,000 edges.
Ratio is the same as
the one we did before.
We're going to make
it undirected--
undirected and unweighted,
undirected, unweighted,
no self loops, so standard
corrections that we do.
We're going to compute
the degree distribution
of that data and plot it.
Or actually, get it there now.
I'm going to then-- we have this
function called power law fit.
So if I compute-- so I compute
the degree distribution.
So we have this function
called out degree which
gives us the distribution.
And I can find, essentially, the
number of values with the one,
and the one that-- our
maximum, so this is estimating
our poor man's slope.
So we're computing the slope.
We're counting the total
number of edges here,
and then we have this
function called power law fit.
Basically, we can plug in
what the estimated alpha is,
what the number of vertices
is, and the number of edges
is to find our best
fit distribution.
So this basically inverts
those formulas I showed you,
which is given a
degree distribution
that sums to a particular
number of vertices and sums
to a particular number
of edges, can you
give me a new D
max and a new ND,
these parameters that don't
really have as much meaning,
to do that?
And so basically,
we use, essentially,
a combination of three
different techniques here.
Because this is so nonlinear,
and there's this-- basically,
remember I talked about integer
bins and logarithmic bins?
Well, if you look at that plot,
it showed there's that bending.
It's a very nasty manifold,
the surface of this function.
And it has a continuous
part and a discrete part.
So what we do here is we do
essentially a sampled search
where we randomly sample,
looking for a location.
We do a heuristic search, which
is a simulated [INAUDIBLE]
search.
And we also use Broyden's
nonlinear-- essentially a
variation of Newton's method to
all try and find the best set
of parameters that
will fit this data.
We rarely get an exact match.
But you can see here it's
choosing different ones.
And this gives you
how it's doing.
From the sample
search, this shows
you the number of vertices
and the number of edges
it was able to achieve.
The heuristic search
didn't do very well at all,
and then the Broyden search
did a pretty good job,
and it got us pretty well.
So actually, it ended up
comparing all of these,
and it ended up choosing the
sample search-- this one,
this first one I did.
It liked that best of all.
So we'll look at that here.
So Figure 2 was
the original data.
Figure 1 shows you the
manifold of this space.
And so plotted in
this coordinate system
of n versus m, the dot
is the dot that it found.
It's actually here
in this [INAUDIBLE]
these lines show the boundaries.
But you can see this very
nonlinear manifold here.
This is the continuous regime.
This is the integer regime.
It cusps right at
the transition.
Again, a very nasty
function to try and invert,
which is why we used all
those different techniques
to invert it.
And then Figure 3
shows the results.
So this black line shows
the original model input
that we provided.
So that was the true model.
The circle shows the data
after it was transformed.
We made it undirected,
unweighted with no self loops.
That's this.
Alpha is-- this is
our poor man's alpha.
What you can see
is almost identical
to the original model.
So the poor man's alpha
does a very good job
of fitting in this case.
The triangle shows
the model fit.
So when we fit the data, we came
up with that best fit it shows,
and we then created
a new distribution.
This is what it looked like.
And then the plus sign
shows us rebinning that data
onto the bins from the model.
And you see that we've done
a very nice job of recovering
the original power
law distribution even
after we did that distortion.
So again, that is
the last example.
So I want thank you.
And then for the
homework, a lot of you
did Homework 2, which is great.
I think Homework 3
wasn't such a great hit.
I'm going to definitely
rethink that one.
But the next homework
does not require
you to have done homework 3.
If you did homework
2, basically,
it's just saying compute
a degree distribution.
And in fact, you don't even
need to have done Homework 2.
You can compute a
degree distribution
on your Homework 2, or you can
compute a degree distribution
on any data set.
For example, today is Halloween.
If you go trick or treating
with somebody-- yourself,
your children, somebody
else's children,
you can maybe email me the
histogram of your candy
and plot it on a
degree distribution,
and maybe compute the poor man's
alpha coefficient from that.
And the other coefficients
from that would be a fun
exercise to do.
So that'll be the next homework.
I'll email that out in
the next couple of days.
So look forward.
Again, if you send
me the homework
prior to next-- actually, just
a reminder, no class next week.
This room has been taken.
But again, if you email me the
homework prior to this time
next week, I will give
you feedback on it.
You can still send me
the homework after that.
I just won't give you
any feedback on it.
So thank you again,
and look forward
to seeing you in two weeks.